down with the dictator they shout for
months Rising food and energy costs has
brought protesters onto moldova's
streets but the government's accused
Russia of deliberately stoking the anger
by pushing up prices spreading
propaganda and backing a plot to
overthrow them
something Moscow and moldova's
pro-russian politicians dispute we are
supporting the protest because the life
in our country became too difficult we
as the Parliamentary reflection and in
parliamentary party we don't feel this
interference
moldova's pro-western President says
they're fighting a hybrid War under
attack from Kremlin interference as it
tries to destabilize Ukraine's Neighbors
from a coup attempt to hundreds of bomb
hoaxes to internet hacks in the last
year moldova's government says it's
faced an explosion of security threats
here's an example of growing Russian
interference this is an old video of a
military parade in Romania but it
quickly became an alarmist social media
post shared by pro-russians in Moldova
with warnings the tanks were heading for
their border
monitoring group Watchdog MD claims
Russian disinformation has rocketed
tenfold in the last year we are feeling
the the pressure even from here from
kishuno so basically what I would say is
the the future of the country not to be
too pathetic about it uh lies at stake
but public opinion is divided in the
pro-russian autonomous region of gagosia
many feel closer to Moscow than the West
at the market no one I speak to believes
Russia is a threat like Valentina they
fondly remember their Soviet past
the government says that Russia is
trying to stir up trouble and interfere
in politics here do you believe that
do you trust President Putin
we believe in everyone she says if a
person is attacked he has to defend his
people
while this local TV station broadcasts
news in Russian many here get their
updates directly from Kremlin control
channels if there was a war between
Russia and Moldova which side do you
think people here would support
I think probably Russia I don't know if
that would happen but more people would
support Russia he says
but it's not Russian troops Moldova has
to fight the enemy here is invisible the
battlefield largely online Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Moldova